bonsoir messieurs chez merci d'être avec
nous ce soir sur rtl france voudrait
qu'on commence avec vous bono megaman
qu'on fait un point sur la situation
aujourd'hui à l'hôpital dont l'hexagone
écoutez le nombre de contaminations est
à la baisse il cette baisse est
relativement non
avec une tendance
on va dire à ceux à se situer sur un
plateau de fait nous avons atteint le
pic d admission à l'hôpital néanmoins le
nombre de patients
qui est dans nos services restent encore
élevés environ 45 % des lits on met trop
pâle est occupé par des passionnés
lakovic 19 nous avons et c'est ça le
point pourtant toujours des entrants
qui viennent donc de nouveaux patients
contaminés qui entrent dans nos services
pour des formes graves de lakovic 19 à
nouveau le point important c'est la
quasi totalité de tous ces patients ne
sont pas vaccinés qu'est-ce que vous
répondrez à sa gérard filoche est ce que
finalement le pas sanitaire l'extension
du passani terre n'a pas conduit à une
obligation de fait de la vaccination
ce qui se démontre à l'hôpital monod
mega man vient de dire aujourd'hui
majoritairement les gens qui sont
hospitalisés sont des gens qui ne sont
pas d'accéder est-ce que emmanuel macron
à a choisi la bonne stratégie selon vous
mais vous savez je suis à 100% pour la
vaccination des je pense clairement
qu'avec le vaccin il ya moins de risque
que 100 le vaccin
donc il faut convaincre le maximum de
nos concitoyens et je pense que c'est
plutôt les explications et la pédagogie
qui permettent de vous faire et le pass
and i ter et la répression nourrissent
les actuels manifestation il faut donc
se rapprocher le vaccin des gens et non
pas menacer les gens qui n'ont pas de
vaccin
c'est un processus qui est en cours nous
n'avons plus de 50 millions de vaccinés
ça produit des effets je l'entends dans
les hôpitaux plutôt
meilleure et donc je crois que c'est pas
le moment de menacer les gens
licenciements et je reste toujours pas
occupé par la situation des entreprises
c'est mon souci numéro un qu'est ce qui
se passe avec les menaces de mise à pied
de suspension de salaire et de
licenciement je pense que c'est
contreproductif il faut que les gens
puissent voir leur médecin du travail
puisse discuter avec lui pour que les
médecins du travail se prononce sur
l'attitude ou d'inaptitude et que les
patrons soient obligés de replacer
jusqu'à ce qu'on obtienne le résultat
pédagogique voulu pour lutter contre le
virus et je me m'étonne que dans les
manifestations en ce moment il n'y ait
pas de banderoles pour les droits des
salariés se voient pas de banderole
contre les licenciements soient pas de
banderole contre les patrons qui font
une passion énorme je vois pas de
banderole en faveur de la médecine du
travail ne vois pas de banderole en
faveur du respect du droit des
travailleurs et ça ça me chagrine
beaucoup je sens bien l'inquiétude des
gens mais je sens aussi cette
contradiction en bas de chez moi et un
bout de manifestation qui est passé les
gens criaient nous sommes des gaulois
nous voulons pas d'étrangers je me
demande bien ce que ça à faire avec la
bataille pour notre santé publique pour
nos hôpitaux publics et pour notre
sécurité sociale je voudrais qu'il y ait
comme le 5 octobre prochain des
manifestations qu'ils soient sociales et
tu poses ce que ces mots d'ordre là en
même temps que ceux qui occupent tous
nos concitoyens c'est à dire les
salaires la dignité dans l'emploi le
rejet de la précarité tout ça c'est des
bons instruments sociaux avec le vaccin
pour nous protéger du virus et leur s
est malheureusement le résultat la
violence et des contradictions de mâcon
et pour revenir sur la situation
sanitaire bruno mais gare d'alès que ce
pas sanitaire vous semble avoir été vous
semble être primordial pour endiguer
l'épidémie de vide
mais coûte il a permis en tout cas au
moment de son annonce à la suite de
l'intervention du président de la
république
et puis depuis son application
il a permis évidemment
une reprise de façon importante des
vaccinations notamment de toutes ces
personnes qui hésitent et qui attendait
qu'ils n'étaient pas sûrs qui finalement
se sont fait vacciner alors évidemment
peut-être pas toujours pour les raisons
logiques mais plutôt parce qu'il voulait
partir en vacances parce qu'il voulait
pouvoir
reprendre leur vie sociale mais en tout
cas le résultat est là ils se sont
vaccinés aujourd'hui à peu près 50
millions de français ont été vaccinés ce
qui fait d'ailleurs de la france l'un
des premiers pays dans le monde en
termes de couverture vaccinale et ça
c'est essentiel car évidemment ça fera
la différence lorsque la circulation de
virus va reprendre en septembre octobre
à l'occasion du refroidissement du
climat à l'occasion de la reprise des
écoles et des universités et donc on
verra effectivement un certain
découplage entre les contaminations et
les hospitalisations
comme d'ailleurs c'est le cas dans les
autres pays comme le royaume uni ou
l'islande qui sont un peu en avance sur
nous en termes de calendrier où on
observe ce découplage mais
malheureusement il risquerait d'y avoir
toujours des patients hospitalisés car
comme vous le savez deux millions de
personnes à risque âgées ou avec comme
invités ne sont toujours pas vaccinées
et c'est là une des limites je la corde
du pass vaccinale c'est que
malheureusement ce ces personnes
finalement n'ont pas ressenti de
contrainte par le pass vaccinale et ne
se sont pas fait vacciner c'est pourquoi
il faut associer le pass vaccinale
désormais à des mesures
pour aller chercher ces personnes car
évidemment il en va de leur vie c'est ça
le plus important est alors plus de
pédagogie
plus plus de pédagogie gérard filoche si
le past and i ter fait débat visiblement
c'est moins le cas concernant la
vaccination les chiffres parlent d'eux
mêmes c'est donc plus de 70% de la
population française totale qui a
désormais un schéma vaccinal
complet est ce qu'il n'aurait pas été
plus simple finalement de rendre
la vaccination obligatoire pour tous
c'est ce que politiquement c'est quelque
chose qui ont été envisageable
je répète que s'il ya une progression de
la vaccination
c'est malgré le paf sanitaires c'est
malgré les menaces de répression c'est
malgré et lançant des des droits qui
sont enlevés deux avec le licenciement
est mise à pied il n'y a que la
persuasion et monsieur vient de me dire
un argument terrible terriblement
favorable et des cas 2 millions de
personnes qui sont âgés sans doute dans
ma tranche d'âge et qui ne sont pas
venus et c'est pas le pass sanitaire qui
les fera venir évidemment c'est une
bêtise de penser que parce sanitaires
tous les gens il faut que le vaccin ait
chez eux faucon lutte contre la fracture
sociale qu'on lutte contre la fracture
médicale conclut il comptait déserts
médicaux combes lutte contre le fait que
les gens n'aient pas assez souvent voir
le médecin généraliste proche d'eux qui
pourrait convaincre c'est ça qui est
1000 fois supérieur à l'idée du pass
sanitaire croire que c'est pas en
menaçant les gens qu'ils viennent ce
n'est pas vrai c'est en les intéressant
les euros expliquant et en faisant les
moyens nécessaires pour que chacun soit
concerné pour que le vaccin est chez les
gens et non pas dire aux gens sortent et
aller à telle heure maintenant allez
vous faire piquer sinon on vous vire et
je pense le le pic le temps passe et que
l'augmentation de la vaccination se fait
on le voit bien c'est pas par la
répression j'imagine que vous en
discutez avec
vos collègues médecins aussi bonhomme
égard balle est ce que vous sentez
aujourd'hui ce besoin cette nécessité de
convaincre les patients qui ne sont pas
encore de faire vacciner contre le
cabinet ce sera ma dernière question
oui tout à fait effectivement monsieur
filochard raison désormais une part de
la population peu accessibles les
personnes âgées isolées sans médecin
traitant il faut faire le maximum pour
pouvoir non seulement les amener le
vaccin à eux mais aussi les convaincre
c'est un rôle très important de la
médecine générale des pharmacies de
ville et peut-être des médecins
hospitaliers spécialistes qui pourraient
être amenés à les voir malheureusement
il y a aussi une fraction il faut
l'avouer de personnes vaccinées aux
sceptiques qui on est et on va dire
intoxiqué par
un certain nombre d'arguments de
désinformation qui traînent sur les
réseaux sociaux et dans une certaine
presse et c'est dommage car
effectivement toutes ces personnes
risqueraient à nouveau de se retrouver
chez nous en réanimation dans les mois
qui viennent et de devoir passer du
temps pour lutter pour la survie est
évidemment d'encombrer les services
d'augmenter la pression et la charge de
travail pour le personnel est de réduire
finalement l'offre de soins hospitalière
pour les autres patients merci beaucoup
à tous les deux d'avoir participé à cet
échange ce soir bono mais garbal chefs
de service réanimation à l'hôpital
lariboisière et gérard filoche porte
parole de la gauche démocratique et
sociale